(announcers laughing)
(exciting music)
- And we are at capacity tonight
here at the opulent
Tostito's Center.
50,000 fans are ready to binge
drink for a couple of hours.
I tell you what, I can't wait.
Hi, I'm grown man, Chick Sarica.
- And I'm grown
man, Bob DiSanzio.
- That's right, Bob.
And we have both made careers
watching adult men play
a simple child's game.
All well being paid
more than the president.
- (chuckling) Okay, Chick.
(whistle blows)
And it seems as though
the millionaires
are ready to play their game
so we can stop stalling
with the mindless chatter.
- And the Rhinos put
the ball into play.
- And the alleged rapist
passes the big orange ball
to the sweaty legal giant.
A-a-a-and.
- Sir Slammage.
- The legal giant easily puts
the ball into the basket,
making it look easy, which if
you're seven feet tall, it is.
- He made about $8,000
while he was doing that.
(Bob laughs)
Now the Power Falcons are
bringing the ball into play.
The high school drop out inbound
to the convicted spousal abuser.
He slashes through all
of the drug addicts
stubs the ball off
of the genetic freak
a-a-a-and.
- Boom quack-a-lack-a.
Two points.
Downtown.
- Stir plackus.
- Bingo time.
- Sturm scams.
- Mmmless a-badda badda.
- I'm just saying words
that start with S.
- I'm going pure nonsense.
(Chick laughing)
(whistle blows)
(horn resounds)
- Are you okay?
- I'm great, Bob.
(acapella music)
- What a mind blowing finish
to an incredible game tonight
with Charlie Sanders
winning the game
in literally the last second.
(players chattering)
Unbelievable.
Truly spectacular.
Charlie Sanders,
how does it feel?
- Hey, yo, I wanna say
something to everybody watching.
Yo, you can do anything.
Anything's possible.
The world is yours.
- Charlie, did you
think that that game
was gonna end that way tonight?
- Yo, there are no
limits, all right?
You can swim across
the Atlantic.
You can jump real high
and touch the moon.
- Fantastic.
Charlie Sanders fresh
off of his victory.
Just feel like he's
ready to touch the moon.
- I can fly.
Anybody can fly.
If you believe in yourself
the way I believe in myself
tonight, you will fly.
- And what's next for Charlie
Sanders and the Orange Rhi-
- Kids, you can actually fly.
- No, no not, well,
not literally.
- Yes, literally,
kids, young kids.
I want you go up on
your roofs right now.
- Wait, what?
- Fly into the nice sky.
- Okay.
- People will see you flying
and you can do anything.
You can do anything.
- Okay, well, we, we, we, uh.
We just wanna remind the
kids that, of course,
you cannot actually fly, kids.
- Come on.
Yo, screw that negativity, man.
Hey, boys and girls,
ages 8 through 12.
Yo, don't let
nobody ever tell you
what you can and cannot do.
All them preteen
children out there.
Listen to my voice.
You are immortal.
- Okay, well, obviously,
we understand that
Charlie is super
excited right now
and that no one is
actually immortal.
Nobody at all.
- Hey, kids.
You can turn yourself into a car
and have a friend drive
you onto the freeway.
- Okay, no, well, that's
just a metaphor, kids.
- It's not.
- Just a metaphor.
- You still have the power
of childish innocence.
Get a friend on your
back and make a bee line
for the next ramp to
the freeway, ya'll.
- Okay, don't do it.
- To the freeway.
- He's speaking
figuratively, folks.
- Once you get there,
ain't nothing
figurative about this,
you will turn into a robot.
First and foremost,
I just wanna say
to the 12 families who
lost children, I'm sorry.
My statements were
irresponsible.
I have subsequently
looked up the terms
literally and metaphorically,
and found that, whereas
I was not incorrect,
they did not mean what I
thought they had meant.
(percussive music)
(ball swooshes)
(players laugh)
(ball bounces)
- Ohh!
(horn resounds)
- [Announcer] Dunk the Vote.
- This November, you
gotta get out and vote.
(ball swooshes)
(crowd cheers)
- It's all about
democracy, y'all.
Your vote gets
counted with the rest
of the votes in the country
and then get sent off to
the electoral college.
- What's that?
- The electoral college
are a bunch of officials
who do the voting for us.
So in case we elect
the wrong person,
they can fix that shiz.
- Whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, hold up.
Who the hell are these people?
- Well, no one knows for sure,
but whoever they is,
they the folks who
actually do the real voting
after we do our pretend vote.
- Yeah.
- Power to the peo-
- Hold the (beep) on.
You're telling me our
votes don't matter?
- Our votes are
like suggestions.
- So this November we should?
- Yeah.
- [Both] Dunk the Vote.
(dramatic music)
- Welcome back.
We're here talking with
all-star shooting guard
Charlie Sanders about
his amazing career.
Now Charlie, you grew up
in a tough neighborhood,
didn't you?
- That's right.
Drugs, violence.
My whole life I had to
deal with adversity.
- And that continued when
you went on to the pros?
- That's right.
You know, fines,
injuries, everything.
No matter how big a star I am,
I'm always gonna be
dealing with adversity.
- Adversity Johnson,
what's your take on this?
- I don't know, girl.
I just (beep) with
him, 'cause unhh.
- Ah, come on, Adversity.
Deal with me, dog.(laughs)
(hand smacks)
(chair clatters)
(he squeals)
I said deal with me.
- Tsk.
Always, wherever we go.
It's-
(feet thump)
- Come on.
No, don't, don't drink my water.
Don't drink my water.
Adversity, leave me some.
Leave me a sip.
Damn, come on, man.
(hand smacks)
Aah.
- Deal with me. (squealing)
- He doesn't.
I'm sorry.
No, he doesn't pick
up social cues.
What? Here he-
Aah.
- Deal with me.
- Titty twister.
Titty twister.
Come on.
- Are you okay?
- No.
- Police say late last night,
they apprehended Rodney Gullivan
and found a gun and
narcotics in his truck.
He was charged with possession
and assault on his fiance
and she's in the hospital
recovering tonight.
Meanwhile, another woman
was sexually assaulted
by Benjamin Brader
of Indianapolis.
The unidentified woman
suffered a broken rib
and a split lip.
She's in stable
condition tonight.
Well, that's it for sports.
Chuck.
(dramatic music)
- Welcome to Metta World News.
Our top story,
a professional athlete
should never post online
looking for people to
live action role play
Hunger Games with them.
I'm sorry, Gerard,
Kaylee, and Zach.
Well that wraps up
Metta World News
for this Wednesday, August
microwave wood chipper.
I'm Metta World Peace.
Goodnight.
(dramatic music)
Welcome to Metta World News.
Our top story.
Why are people always
trying to steal my magic?
In other news, cat
litter can be used
to blind people when fighting.
Interesting, I didn't know that.
Well, that wraps
up Metta World News
for this Wednesday, February
biscuit fountain drink.
I'm Metta World Peace.
Goodnight.
(dramatic music)
Welcome to Metta World News.
In sports.
I'd rather eat my hand than
to have my penis cut off.
I'd really have to believe
someone was gonna cut it off,
but if I did, I can
definitely eat my hand.
I know because I had a
dream where I did it.
It was horrible.
I ate my whole hand.
Now that's what
you call rhetoric.
Well, that wraps
up Metta World News
for this Wednesday,
April hurricane slipknot.
I'm Metta World Peace.
Goodnight.
(dramatic music)
Welcome to Metta World News.
In fashion.
If you woke up
and there was a
four-inch miniature human
standing on your chest,
would you swat them off?
I was really challenged
by this question.
I would hope that I'd
engage them in conversation.
But in reality, I think
I'd be scared of them
and swat them away, which
would probably kill them.
Well, that wraps
up Metta World News
for this Wednesday, October
noise-canceling octagon tire.
I'm Metta World Peace.
Goodnight.
Did I fulfill my
contract, Satan?
(dramatic music)
- Welcome to Metta World News.
I wish there was
a genie in here.
Well, that wraps
up Metta World News
for this Wednesday,
March, hybrid ice rink.
I'm Metta World Peace.
Goodnight.
Hey Jim, where's that genie?
(dramatic music)
Welcome to Metta World News.
Our top story.
Ninja costumes don't
come in size triple X,
which is discriminatory
against enormous assassins.
You know what?
Forget about the teleprompter.
I need to speak from the heart.
Well, that wraps
up Metta World News
for this Wednesday May
staple gun hairbrush.
I'm Metta World Peace.
Goodnight.
(dramatic music)
Welcome to Metta World News.
Our top story.
The Pope is thinking of
moving out the Vatican
so feral cats can live there.
Now let's go to Homemaker's
Corner with Metta World Peace.
Thank you, Metta.
You need five
plastic grocery bags
to make an effective parachute.
Thanks, Metta.
And you will die
if you try that.
Well, that wraps
up Metta World News
for this Wednesday, November
morning star, cocktail napkin.
I'm Metta World Peace.
Goodnight.
(dramatic music)
Welcome to Metta World News.
In science news.
It is impossible to knock
yourself out with your own fist.
Let's not fall behind, America.
Well, that wraps
up Metta World News
for this Wednesday
biscuit biscuit biscuit.
I'm Metta World Peace.
Goodnight.
You win, fish.
Now I'm the one in the aquarium.
(acapella music)
♪ Oh I want you ♪
♪ But I don't need you ♪